is the toughest thing to deal with Aaron
Carter dropping a major bombshell on
Thursday alleging on Twitter that his
late sister Leslie who died in 2012
sexually abused him when he was a child
in a series of tweets the singer
explained quote my sister raped me from
the age of 10 to 13 years old when she
wasn't on her medications he also
alleged I was abused not only sexually
by her but by my first two backup
dancers when I was eight years old and
my brother abused me my whole life
et has reached out to Nick Carter for
comment
Aaron claims the abuse in question came
as a result of his late sister Leslie's
mental health issues he says she
suffered from bipolar disorder and took
lithium to treat it claiming that when
she was not on her meds she did things
that she never meant to do as a result
Aaron says he spent the last 15 years of
his life going to therapy
he says he's had ups and downs and will
continue working on his mental health
Aaron also points out that even though
he's been through extensive therapy
he's never been diagnosed bipolar or
schizophrenic even though he said he'd
been diagnosed with the disorders on the
doctors I suffer from multiple
personality disorder schizophrenia acute
anxiety a manic-depressive Aaron's
claims of abuse come days after Nick got
a restraining order against him
according to court docket entry for
himself his wife Lauren son Odin and
mother and father-in-law which states
Aaron must stay a hundred feet away from
them in a tweet Aaron denied wanting to
hurt anyone especially his family there
it's so bad because there's like nothing
I can do about it